One of my favorite things to do with my family is to go on a road trip. We are road trippers. Josh and I love to pack up the car and hit the road with our kids. And I just love the sense of adventure of exploring new places. And we love to use Airbnb. We love staying in a home. We love having a kitchen, having some type of backyard, our patio to sit on at night.
我最喜欢和家人一起做的事情之一就是去公路旅行。我们是公路旅行达人。乔什和我喜欢收拾好车，带着孩子们上路。我就是喜欢探索新地方的那种冒险感。而且我们喜欢用Airbnb。我们喜欢住在家里。我们喜欢有个厨房，有个某种后院，或者晚上可以坐的露台。
I love the privacy of it. And also it just feels like you're still at home even though you're on this adventure because you make your own home. And you know, Airbnb is just so great for families because you can really pick a place that suits your whole group. You know, we did that one year with my family.
我喜欢它的私密性。而且它也让人感觉你依然身处家中，尽管你正在经历这场冒险，因为你打造了自己的家。你知道，Airbnb对家庭来说真是太棒了，因为你真的可以挑选一个适合你们整个团队的地方。你知道，有一年我和家人就这么做了。
We all met up in the mountains and picked this great Airbnb and all stayed in it together. Cousins and nieces and nephews and aunts and uncles. It was so much fun and it was so cozy. And Airbnb really made that family memory special. So use Airbnb for your next adventure. There's so many things I wanna do and see. Like redoing the basement without having to do it all myself. next adventure. Performance matter. And now you can get $300 when you invest with RBC. Offer ends March 3rd, 2025. Terms and conditions apply.
我们全都在山里聚齐，选了这个绝佳的Airbnb，然后一起住在了那里。表兄弟姐妹、侄女侄子、阿姨和叔叔。太有趣了，而且非常温馨。Airbnb真的让那个家庭记忆变得特别。所以，为你的下一次冒险预订Airbnb吧。我有很多事情想做、想看。比如重修地下室，又不用自己一个人全干完。下一次冒险。表现至关重要。现在，只要通过RBC投资，你就可以获得300加元。优惠截至2025年3月3日。条款和条件适用。
Invest with RBC today. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details and lots of VFF stories.
今天就通过RBC投资。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你打造终极的办公室爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后花絮以及大量VFF的故事，带你更深入地了解《办公室》的世界。
We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello. Hey there. I'm smiling again. I know it's the second part of the edge and you couldn't be more tickled. Yes everyone, welcome back. You know, once we got into it,
我们是《办公室辣妈 6.0》。你好。嘿。我又在笑了。我知道这是“边缘”的第二部分，你别提有多高兴了。是的，各位，欢迎回来。你知道，一旦我们深入探讨起来，
we realized we had a lot to say about this movie. Yeah, we needed to make it a two parter. Because it's so good. I think Angela, wouldn't you agree it's just because it's so good, there's so much to say? There is a lot to say. Wait, but it's because it's so good. It's good, lady.
我们意识到关于这部电影我们有太多话要说了。是的，我们需要把它分成两部分。因为太棒了。我想安吉拉，你也会同意，纯粹是因为太棒了，所以才有这么多话要说吧？确实有很多话要说。等等，但这正是因为太棒了。太棒了，女士。
It's good. It's so stressful for me, but I'm here for you. You know, maybe if that reviewer guy, James, listens to our breakdown, he'll gain a new appreciation for the movie. Wow. You are still really sour about James. I might write him a letter. He might get a letter from me.
太棒了。对我来说压力太大了，但我支持你。你知道，也许如果那个影评人詹姆斯听了我们的剖析，他会对这部电影有全新的赏识。哇。你对詹姆斯还是很有意见啊。我可能会给他写封信。他可能会收到我写的一封信。
He's gonna be so confused because he wrote his review in 1997. Yeah, you know what? It's never too late. It's never too late. But first, I said last week that I would tell you what to do in a bear attack. Oh, I have been waiting for this. I'm grabbing my cup of tea. Well, let's get to it. First of all, brown bears, like the one in the movie, are more aggressive than black bears. However, the chances of being attacked by a bear are exceedingly rare. But it does happen. And according to all the experts, staying alive during a bear attack requires a presence of mind that is difficult for humans to muster under pressure.
他会一头雾水的，因为他的影评是1997年写的。对，你知道吗？永远都不晚。永远都不晚。但首先，我上周说过我会告诉你遇到熊袭击时该怎么做。哦，我一直在等这个呢。我正在拿我的茶杯。好吧，我们言归正传吧。首先，棕熊，就像电影里的那只，比黑熊更具攻击性。然而，被熊袭击的几率极其微小。但这种事确实会发生。根据所有专家的说法，在熊的袭击中保命需要一种心理准备，而人类在压力下很难保持这种冷静。
You think if a 1700 pound thing swats you and you go flying that you're gonna be like I'm gonna think right now. Well, this is why humans don't do well during bear attacks because we can't think ourselves out of the situation. You can't process what's happening. Yeah. The injury patterns for bear attacks include blows to the face, head, chest, neck, and upper extremities most likely. And even if you do survive the attack, your injuries can be anything from like major lacerations to fractures. You know like when the bear is just like pouncing on your chest, it's just like crushing your rib cage, to like internal organ damage. These are all things that are more likely to kill you than the lacerations actually. The
你觉得一个1700磅重的家伙扇你一下，然后你飞了出去，你会觉得自己当时还能冷静思考吗？好吧，这就是为什么人类在遭遇熊袭击时表现不佳，因为我们无法在那种情况下理智思考。你根本无法处理正在发生的事情。是的。熊袭击的受伤模式最有可能包括面部、头部、胸部、颈部和上肢受到重击。而且，即使你在袭击中幸存下来，你的伤势也可能从严重撕裂伤到骨折不等。你知道的，就像当熊猛扑到你的胸口上，直接压碎你的胸廓，一直到内脏器官受损。这些其实都是比撕裂伤更有可能致命的情况。
National Park Service said that the most important thing to do if you encounter an approaching bear is to stand your ground. Do not run. Instead, you're supposed to wave your arms, try to look or become as big as possible, even if it means you have to try to get up on a hill or something. But never scream and never, ever make bear sounds. Don't growl at the bear. And then when you move away you're supposed to go sideways. Don't go backwards because that is seen as like retreating. Yeah,
国家公园管理局表示，如果你遇到一头迎面走来的熊，最重要的事情是坚守阵地。不要逃跑。相反，你应该挥舞手臂，尽量让自己看起来很高大或尽可能变大，哪怕这意味着你必须设法爬到小山丘或什么地方。但绝不要尖叫，也绝不能发出熊的声音。不要对熊咆哮。然后当你移开时，你应该横着走。不要倒退着走，因为那会被视为是在撤退。是的，
try to go sideways. So you, okay, let me see. I think I've got this. Okay. Wave your arms around. Yep. Don't make a sound. Side step. Yep. If the bear charges you, this is where I think, I don't know how you do this. Do you charge it back? Nope.
尽量横着走。所以你，好吧，让我看看。我想我明白了。好的。挥舞你的手臂。是的。不要发出声音。侧着步走。是的。如果熊向你冲过来，这就是我觉得——我不知道你怎么应对这种情况。你要冲回去吗？不。
You just stand there. Ugh. What about laying down and playing dead? No, no, no. No. They'll just flop you around. In most cases, a bear will veer off at the last minute. It's just like a really intense game of chicken. The vast majority of bears are uninterested
你就站在那儿。呃。那躺下装死呢？不，不，不。不。它们只会把你翻来翻去。在大多数情况下，熊会在最后一刻转向离开。这就像是一场非常激进的胆小鬼游戏。绝大多数熊都对人类不感兴趣，一旦它们靠得足够近——比如如果它们在向你冲锋——一旦它们靠得足够近到能闻到你的气味并认出你是人类，它们就应该撤退并走开。但熊会攻击任何它认为是逃跑猎物的目标。国家公园管理局表示，要特别小心母熊和幼崽，绝不要夹在母熊和她的幼崽中间。如果它们成排走着，不要穿过去。绝对不要夹在它们中间。
in humans and once they get close enough, like if they're charging you, once they get close enough to smell you and recognize you as human, they should retreat and go away. But a bear will attack anything that it deems to be fleeing prey. The National Park Service says to be especially cautious of mama bears and cubs, never get in the middle of a mama bear and her cubs. If they're walking in a line, don't cross it. Do not get in the middle of them.
还有，不要爬树逃跑。它们会追上你的。如果你正试图逃离一熊并且背着背包，请把它留着，因为这或许能起到保护作用。如果灰熊或棕熊真的攻击了你，请平趴在肚子上，双手抱住脖子后面，并将双腿分得开开的，这样熊就没法把你翻过身来。如果你以任何方式试图反击，可能会激化袭击的程度。
Also, do not climb a tree to get away. They will get you. If you're trying to escape a bear and you're wearing a backpack, keep it on because this might serve as protection. If a grizzly or a brown bear does attack you, lie flat on your stomach with your hands behind your neck and spread your legs so that the bear can't flip you over. If you try to fight back in any way, it might increase the intensity of the attack.
所以你想把绝地反击留作最后手段。如果你觉得自己正处于像电影里史蒂芬那样的绝境……攻击鼻子？脸。找个物体砸熊的脸。比如，试着找块石头，狠狠地砸熊的脸。嗯哼。那是对付棕熊的方法。如果黑熊攻击你，不要装死。
So you want to save fighting back as a last resort. If you feel like you're in a last resort situation like Steven was in the movie... Go for the nose? The face. Find an object and hit the bear in the face. Like, try to find a rock and just smash the bear's face Mm-hmm. That's for brown bears. If a black bear attacks you don't play dead
你看，在这个时刻你必须注意这么多事情。好吧，你刚才说对付棕熊要坚守阵地。不要装死。直到它攻击你时才装死。并且分开双腿，护住腹部。海星状。对，就是这样。如果黑熊在攻击你，据说要设法进入关闭的车辆或建筑物中。我的意思是，废话。问题是，如果你身处熊出没的地方，到哪儿去找关闭的建筑物或车辆啊。我不知道。但在极少数情况下，如果一头熊在尾随你，甚至可能在你呆在帐篷里的时候袭击你，这就是一只带有捕食性的熊，而反击是唯一的选择。非常，非常罕见。但这确实有点像电影里的这只熊在捕猎人类。电影里的这只熊在捕猎人类。我想偶尔确实会有这种情况。最后，如果你想听一个关于熊袭击的精彩故事。哦，是那个播客吗？赛斯·罗根的故事时间？真的太棒了。是的，他采访了一个击退熊袭击并幸存下来的人。太引人入胜了。引人入胜。发生在加拿大。有各种各样的人讲述他们的目击者式的经历，包括当事人男主角。对。太棒了。我一定会把它分享到动态里，因为我觉得制作得太精良了。是的，斯图。好吧，在我们休息之前，萨姆，你也说你对《边缘》有一个观察想分享。是的。是的。我们得告诉大家，萨姆和卡西都和我们一起看了这部电影，还有艾恩斯利和艾恩斯利。是的。好的，萨姆，
This is look at all you have to be observing in this moment. Well the brown bear you said stand your ground Don't play dead. Until it's attacking you then play dead. And spread your legs and cover your stomach. Starfish. Yep there you go. If a black bear is attacking you it's said to try to get into a closed vehicle or building. I mean duh. I mean where is there a closed building or a vehicle if you're somewhere where they're around. I don't know. But in the rare case that a bear is stalking you and maybe like attacks you while you're in your tent or something, this is a predatorial bear and fighting back is the only option. Very, very rare. But kind of true that like the bear in this movie is hunting the people. bear in this movie is hunting the people. I guess every once in a while. Finally, if you want to hear an amazing story of a bear attack. Oh, is it that podcast? Seth Rogan's Storytime? It is so good. Yes, he interviewed a guy who fought off a bear
你的观察是什么？是的。这部电影的前半部分，在他们遇到熊之前，就是《指环王》。就是《指环王》里三个人穿过森林，一路上抛出各种人生哲理？说实话，大部分都是这样。哇。好吧，我被吸引了。只不过把熊换成了兽人。对，完全是这样。
attack and lived. It is riveting. Riveting. It's in Canada. And there's all these real people that tell their, like, eyewitness sort of accounts of it, including the main guy. Yeah. So good. I will definitely share that in stories because I thought it was so well done. Yes, Stu. Well, before we go to break, Sam, you also said that you had an observation about the Edge that you want to share. Yes. Yes. We should say you guys that both Sam and Cassie watched this with us and Ainsley and Ainsley. Yes. Okay, Sam,
是的。但它们依然想置你于死地。对。也许我会看一看。我doubt。我的意思是，那将会史诗感十足。我们为什么不休息一下，然后再继续剖析《边缘》。安吉拉，你还在关注风向，
what was your observation? Yes. The first half of this movie before they reached the bear is Lord of the Rings. Is Lord of the Rings just like three people walking through a forest, like laying down wisdom? Honestly, most of it, yes. Wow. Well, I'm intrigued. Instead of bears, there's orcs. Yes, exactly.
我这儿还有两条查尔斯的人生哲理要分享给你。本节目由BetterHelp赞助播出。你知道，你经常听到在一段关系中要注意哪些红线。但如果？如果我们改变焦点，开始列一份我们在朋友和伴侣身上寻找的绿灯清单呢？
Yes. But they still want to kill you. Yeah. Maybe I'll watch it. I doubt it. I mean, that would be epic. Why don't we take a break, and then we'll finish breaking down the edge. Angela, you are still tracking the wind,
你知道，与其把它框定为“这是我要避免的”，不如变成“这是我想要奔向的目标”。好吧。如果你不确定你的绿灯清单是什么，心理治疗可以帮你找出它们。你的绿灯清单是什么，心理治疗可以帮你找出它们。而且你知道BetterHelp是完全在线的，让心理治疗变得负担得起且便捷，为全球超过500万用户提供服务。你可以接入
and I've got two more pieces of Charles wisdom for you. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, you often hear about the red flags to look for in a relationship. But what if? What if we changed that focus and started making a list of the green flags that we were looking for in friends and partners?
一个由超过3万名拥有各种专业领域的持证治疗师组成的多元化网络。你还可以随时更换治疗师，无需支付额外费用。通过BetterHelp发现你的关系绿灯。今天就访问BetterHelp.com斜杠office ladies，首月即可享受九折优惠。网址是 Better Help，拼写是 H-E-L-P 点 com 斜杠 office ladies。你的账单都在你的掌控之中吗？你的每月还款额都在轻松搞定吗？听起来你已经走到了办公室辣妈的巅峰。并且每月按时还款。从账单支付者升级为奖励斩获者。条款和条件适用。好了，我们回来了。现在，简单总结一下。以下是上周我们剖析的电影中到目前为止发生的事情。三个男人，鲍勃、查尔斯和斯蒂芬，在他们乘坐的小飞机被一群大雁撞击后，被困在了荒野中。
You know, like more like instead of framing it, here's what I'm avoiding, be like, here's what I wanna run toward. Okay. Well, if you're not sure what your list of green flags is, therapy can help you identify them. And your list of green flags is, therapy can help you identify them. And you know BetterHelp is fully online, making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide. You can access
在荒野中艰难求生时，这群人还一直在被一头熊尾随。然后斯蒂芬在制作长矛时割伤了腿，鲍勃把那块沾满血的破布挂在了一棵树上，而没有按照被告知的那样把它埋起来。他被明确告知要把那块沾血的破布埋掉。而他没有这么做。血腥味引来了熊，熊袭击了他们的营地。斯蒂芬死了。他被熊杀死了。鲍勃和查尔斯还活着，而且在下雪。是的，那是第二天早上。鲍勃和查尔斯熬过了一夜。现在他们挤在一起，雪下得越来越大。你知道，他们还没吃东西。
a diverse network of more than 30,000 credentialed therapists with a wide range of specialties. You can also switch therapists at any time at no extra cost. Discover your relationship green flags with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's Better Help. H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. Are you crushing your bills? Defeating your monthly payments? Sounds like you're at the top office ladies. and on time every month. Level up from bill payer to reward slayer. Terms and conditions apply. All right, we are back. Now, quick summary. Here is what has happened so far in the movie that we broke down last week. Three men, Bob, Charles, and Stephen have been stranded in the wilderness after a small plane they were traveling in was hit by a flock of geese.
他们需要食物。所以查尔斯做了一个小木制陷阱，他们打算试着捉一只松鼠，而且他们真的成功了。太棒了，因为这个镜头就是他们两人的脸从一根圆木后面探出来，带着对吃松鼠的满心期待。但接着在远处他们听到了直升机。对。但他们离空地太远了，他们拼命跑，拼命跑，拼命跑，直升机却没有看到他们。而正是在这个时候，鲍勃
While trying to survive in the wilderness, this group is also being stalked by a bear. And then Stephen cut his leg trying to make a spear and Bob hung the bloody rag on a tree instead of burying it like he was told. He was specifically told to bury the bloody rag. And he didn't. The blood attracted the bear who charged their campsite. Stephen is dead. He was killed by the bear. Bob and Charles are alive and it's snowing. Yeah it's the next morning. Bob and Charles have made it through the night. Now they're huddled together and it is really coming down with some snow. And you know, they haven't eaten.
这是他彻底绝望的时刻。对，查尔斯，我不知道是不是因为，好吧，老实说，这段是我写的，查尔斯，看看气氛吧。他开始对情绪崩溃的鲍勃说，你知道你可以用冰生火吗？你可以用冰生火。鲍勃根本没在听。
They need food. So Charles makes a little wooden trap and they're gonna try to trap a squirrel and they do it. It's so great because the shot is just their two faces peering over a log with such anticipation of eating the squirrel. But then in the distance they hear a helicopter. Yeah. But they are really far from a clearing and they run and they run and they run and the helicopter doesn't see them. And this is when Bob
查尔斯说：“喂，我在跟你说话！你知道这怎么做吗，鲍勃？”而鲍勃气坏了。我只想说，查尔斯，现在没人想听冷知识。你的朋友刚被熊吃掉。你们在挨饿。你们刚刚错失了获救的机会。现在没人想听什么冷知识。对。另外，鲍勃气喘吁吁，但查尔斯却没有。鲍勃跑得更快。好吧。
this is his moment that he becomes absolutely despondent. Yeah, and Charles, I don't know if it's because, well, honestly, I wrote this, Charles, read the room. He starts telling Bob, who's very distraught, he starts saying this, do you know that you can make fire from ice? You can make fire from ice. Bob isn't listening.
他确实跑得更快。好吧。但现在他们意识到就是这样了。那是直升机搜寻该地区的唯一一次机会。他们唯一的选择真的是靠双腿走出这种绝境。他们必须自救。获救不再是一个选项了。没有。鲍勃确实经历了一次彻底的情绪崩溃，你知道的。他对
Charles goes, hello, I'm talking to you! Do you know how that could be done, Bob? And Bob is just so pissed off. And I just want to say, Charles, no one wants to hear trivia right now. Your friend just got eaten by a bear. You're starving. You just missed the opportunity to get rescued. No one wants a little piece of trivia right now. Yeah. Also, Bob is very winded, but Charles is not. Bob ran faster. Okay.
查尔斯发火，说像“你知道吗，你让我感到恶心”，然后紧接着他又哭了。而查尔斯却说：“我们得去河边，我们得沿着河边走才能离开这里。”这两个人开始穿过这个山谷，女士，在影片过去一小时六秒的时候，你能听到风声。风声。呜。这真的让你感到无比孤独和孤立。
He did. Okay. But now they're realizing that's it. That's the only time that helicopter is gonna search that area. Their only option is truly to walk out of this situation. They are going to have to save themselves. Being rescued is no longer an option. No. Bob did have a whole spiral, you know. He goes off on
这就好像他们再也见不到另一个人了一样。这是我为鲍勃情绪崩溃、查尔斯努力想要坚持下去的这一场景所写的感想。我写道，在我经历癌症的过程中——那是我的荒野，我会在扮演鲍勃和扮演查尔斯之间来回摇摆。这就是为什么我喜欢这部电影，因为我觉得这两种观点都存在于我们所有人身上，对吧？比如，在危机时刻，谁会赢？鲍勃还是查尔斯？但我们需要两者。我们需要宣泄。我们需要眼泪。我们需要有质疑。
Charles, says like, you know, you make me sick, and you know, then again he's crying. And Charles is just like, we've got to get to the river, we've got to walk alongside the river to get out of here. And the two men start to walk through this valley and lady, one hour, six seconds, you can hear the wind. The wind. Woo. It really makes you feel so alone and isolated.
我们不是机器人。但最终我们需要查尔斯把我们拉回来，好像在说：“好了，发泄完了吗？你没事了吧？现在让我们向前迈进。”这就是为什么我喜欢这部电影。我觉得我们每个人身上都兼具他们两人的特质。虽然——鲍勃和查尔斯。
It's like they're never going to see another person ever again. Here's what I wrote about this scene where Bob is losing it and Charles is trying to like, you know, carry on carrying on. I wrote during my cancer journey, which was my wilderness, I would go back and forth between being Bob and Charles. And that's why I love this movie, because I feel like these two points of view are in all of us, right? Like, in a moment of crisis, who's going to win? Bob or Charles? But we need both. We need to have the release. We need to have the tears. We need to have the doubt.
鲍勃和查尔斯。然后，你知道，有时候我们是斯蒂芬。有时候情况就是会把我们击垮。就是这样。你无能为力。你不可能每次都赢。我知道。如果你在荒野中，你会是谁？
We aren't robots. But eventually we need Charles to get us, be like, okay, did you get it out? Are you good? And now let's move forward. That's why I love the movie. I feel like we all have both of us in them. Although- Bob and Charles.
就像如果你在这部电影里，如果你正在经历这种字面意义上的事情，而不是隐喻，你是鲍勃、查尔斯还是斯蒂芬？你是谁？哦天哪，我不想成为他们中的任何一个。我不想去那里。我不想再深入荒野80英里甚至更远，特别是当一个刚告诉我
Bob and Charles. And then, you know, then sometimes we're Steven. Sometimes the situation is just gonna get us. It just is. There's nothing you can do. You can't win them all. I know. Who would you be in the wilderness?
鸟类能把飞机撞毁的人说完之后。我不去。你不在那儿。我是米奇。你回木屋里去了。对。萨姆，卡西，你们是谁？我想我是鲍勃。我也是鲍勃，萨姆。
Like if you were in this movie, if you were having this literal thing happen to you, not metaphorical, are you Bob, Charles or Stephen? Who are you? Oh God, I don't wanna be any of them. I don't wanna be out there. I don't wanna go 80 miles and further into the wilderness, especially after a guy just told me
好吧。没关系，没关系。卡西？我确实觉得自己是查尔斯，除非我受伤了，那我就绝对是斯蒂芬了。哦不。是的。是的，我不知道。
that birds can take down this plane. I'm not going. You're not there. I'm Mickey. You're back in the lodge. Yeah. Sam, Cassie, who are you? I think I'm Bob. I'm Bob too, Sam.
我不想去。好吧，让我们看看，我们在哪儿？哦，他们要沿着河边走，查尔斯要去钓鱼，因为他们真的需要吃东西。如果他们找不到食物，就别想活着离开这儿。我不知道他们的松鼠怎么了。他们听到直升机。他们跑了。松鼠还在圆木上的笼子里。我知道。他们不可能回去拿它了。那可是一整只松鼠。我不知道，鲍勃当时非常心烦意乱。好吧，查尔斯在讲冷知识。我要是就会去拿。那是他们犯的另一个错误。好吧，现在他们试图用
Okay. It's okay, it's okay. Cassie? I do think I'm Charles unless I get hurt, then I'm definitely Steven. Oh no. Yeah. Yeah, I don't know.
查尔斯手表上的零件来钓鱼。为了活命，他不得不继续拆解他妻子送的这件礼物。他几乎把整块表都用光了。他确实用光了，但你猜他在钓鱼的时候发生了什么？熊回来啦，各位。嗯哼。它回来了。查尔斯回到营地，他们在营地周围用火围成了一个圈，他们就站在火圈里。正是在这个时候，查尔斯意识到这头熊一直在追踪他们。对。他们只有一个选择。查尔斯说他们必须杀了它。他们必须杀死这头熊。
I don't wanna go. All right, let's see, Where are we? Oh, they are gonna walk along the river and Charles is gonna go fishing because they really need to eat. They're not gonna get out of here if they don't get some food. I don't know what happened to their squirrel. They heard the helicopter. They ran away. The squirrel is still in the cage on the log. I know. They couldn't have gone back for it. It was a whole squirrel. I don't know Bob was very upset. Well Charles was talking trivia. I would have gone to get it. That was another error they made. Yeah well now they're trying to fish using
查尔斯说：“我才不会死在这儿呢。没门。我要杀了这头熊。”这是人生哲理时刻之三。最著名的一个。这是在鲍勃问“怎么杀？我们怎么杀这头熊？”之后，查尔斯说：“我们要利用坠落陷阱的同等原理。”
parts of Charles's watch. He has to keep dismantling this gift from his wife to survive. He uses almost all of it. He does, but guess what happens while he's fishing? The bear comes back y'all. Mm-hmm. He comes back. Charles gets back to the campfire and they they make like a circle of fire around their fire and they're standing in the circle of fire. And this is when Charles realizes that this bear is tracking them. Yeah. And they only have one option. Charles says they're going to have to kill them. They're going to have to kill the bear.
“我们要利用熊自身的重量，当它攻击我们时，让它自己撞到我们削好的长矛上。”鲍勃就问：“那我们怎么把熊引出来呢？”他说：“我们得诱捕它。我们要把熊引到我们这儿来。”只不过查尔斯说的是“lure”（诱捕）。Lure。然后在这个时刻，我们看到了鲍勃的冷嘲热讽。在这个疯狂的、危及生命的时刻，鲍勃说：“不好意思，我们怎么lure？”他模仿着查尔斯。你得听听看。“我们用什么做诱饵啊，查尔斯？”“我们lure它。”“什么？我们lure它。”
Charles says, I'm not going to die here. No siree. I'm going to kill the bear. This is wisdom moment number three. The most famous. This is after Bob says, how? How are we going to kill the bear? And Charles says, we're going to use the same principle as the deadfall.
“你知道的，非洲的马赛男孩，11岁就能用长矛杀死狮子。”“我们怎么lure它？”说真的，鲍勃，我们现在不需要你的冷嘲热讽。不，我们确实不需要。但是女士，查尔斯才不在乎
We're going to use the bear's own weight and we're going to get it to impale itself onto a spear that we've whittled when it's attacking us. And Bob's like, well, how are we going to get the bear to come out? And he's like, we're going to have to lure him. We're going to lure the bear to us. Except Charles says lure. Lure. And then in this moment we have Bob snark. In this crazy life-threatening moment Bob goes I'm sorry how do we lure and he mocks Charles. You have to hear it. What are we going to use to bait him, Charles? We lure him. What? We lure him.
鲍勃那讽刺的态度呢。接下来发生的是我的下一条查尔斯的人生哲理，这也许是我整部电影中最喜欢的查尔斯的演讲。
You know, Maasai boys in Africa, 11 years old, they kill lions with spears. How do we lure him? Seriously, Bob, we don't need your snark right now. No, we do not. But lady, Charles doesn't care about need your snark right now. No, we do not. But lady, Charles doesn't care about Bob's snarky attitude. And what comes next is my next piece of Charles wisdom, and it is maybe my favorite Charles speech in the whole movie.
我有一段音频剪辑。就是这个。我必须分散它的注意力并设法困住它，但这绝对做得到。你相信吗，鲍勃？你相信吗？就是这样。它一直走在我们前面。就像它在读我们的心思一样。看在上帝的份上，它在跟踪我们。看见了吗？你想死在这儿，哈？那你就去死吧。我告诉你，我可不想死。抱歉。我不想死。我要杀了这头熊。
I have a clip. Here it is. I have to distract him and trap him, but it can be done. Do you believe it, Bob? Do you believe it? is. He's ahead of us all the time. It's like he's reading our minds. He's stalking us for God's sake see You want to die out here, huh? Well then die I tell you what I'm not gonna die. I'm sorry. I'm not gonna die I'm gonna kill the bear.
Sid，我要杀了这头熊。Sid，我要杀了这头熊。Sid！Sid，我要杀了这头熊！Sid！我要杀了这头熊。再来一次！我要杀了这头熊。再来一遍！
Sid, I'm gonna kill the bear. Sid, I'm gonna kill the bear. Sid! Sid, I'm gonna kill the bear! Sid! I'm gonna kill the bear. Sid again! I'm gonna kill the bear. And again!
我要杀了这头熊！太棒了！一个人能做到的事，另一个人也能做到。一个人能做到的事，另一个人也能做到。再说一遍！一个人能做到的事，另一个人也能做到。再说一遍！一个人能做到的事，另一个人也能做到！耶！
I'm gonna kill the bear! Good! What one man can do, another can do. What one man can do, another can do. Say it again! What one man can do, another can do. Say it again! What one man can do, another can do! Yeah!
今天，我要干死这个王八蛋。没错，各位。没错。人生哲理时刻之三。一个人能做到的事，另一个人也能做到。我们收到了来自温尼伯的亚历克西斯·B.的来信，她写道：“嗨，办公室辣妈。我今天写信的原因是想向你表达特别的感谢，珍娜。我从未看过《边缘》，对此我深表歉意。我可能也永远不会看了。听起来太吓人了。”
Today, I'm gonna kill the motherf*****. That's right, folks. That's right. Wisdom moment number three. what one man can do, another can do. We got a letter from Alexis B. in Winnipeg who said, Hi, office ladies. The reason I wrote today is that I want to send a special thank you to you, Jenna. I have never seen The Edge, and I'm so sorry. I likely never will. It sounds too scary.
“但珍娜对这部电影的台词引用这段时间一直在我的脑海里回响，帮助我度过了一些更具挑战性的时刻。提醒自己‘一个人能做到的事，另一个人也能做到’，这给隧道尽头带来了光亮，即使我不知道关于这只熊的完整故事是怎样的。一如既往，非常感谢你们两人的脆弱、动力、笑声，以及你们
But Jenna's quoting of the film has been playing in my head this last while, helping me to get through some more challenging times. Reminding myself that what one man can do, another can do, has brought light at the end of the tunnel, even if I don't know what the whole story is with the bear. As always, thank you both very much for your vulnerability, motivation, laughter, and your
美丽的友谊。期待你们未来的所有节目，以及我在此过程中无疑会反复重温的那些单集。”好吧，亚历克西斯，我专门为你播放了这段音频剪辑，好让你能听到它。你不需要看整部电影，亚历克西斯。或者你可以听播客，这样你就不用那么害怕了。没错。我们在为你剖析它，但一个人能做到的事，另一个人也能做到。萨姆，你说你今天早上醒来时就在引用这句台词。是的，我独自一人在公寓里一边煎鸡蛋一边转悠着说：“一个人能做到的事，
beautiful friendship. Looking forward to all your future episodes and the ones I will undoubtedly re-listen to along the way. Well, Alexis, I played this audio clip just for you so that you could hear it. You don't have to watch the whole movie, Alexis. Or you can listen to the podcast and then you don't have to be super scared. That's right. We were breaking it down for you, but what one man can do another can do. Sam, you said you woke up this morning quoting it. Yes, I was walking around making eggs in my apartment alone going, but one man can do
另一个人也能做到。”纯粹是在为自己一整天的工作打气。是的，这真是一句非常棒的打气台词。确实如此。真的超级棒。我太喜欢了，女士。我太喜欢了。好吧，各位，我必须——抱歉，这没有刚才那个那么有力量，但我必须分享，在影片一小时十五分四十秒的时候，风声又回来了。风声在这部电影里对我来说太萦绕耳际了。你猜怎么着？它在吹拂着
another man can do. Just hyping myself up for the day. Yeah, it's a really good hype line. It is. It really is. I love it lady. I love it. Well you guys, I have to, sorry, this is not as powerful as that, but I have to share at one hour 15 minutes and 40 seconds, the wind is back. The wind is so haunting to me in this movie. Guess what? It is blowing
他们系在长矛顶端的那个血迹斑斑的布条。他们打算用血腥味来引诱这头熊。在等待熊出现的两多分钟里，没有任何对话。只有风声和等待，这太诡异了，我觉得你们必须听听看。这是两分钟的风声？是的。好吧。很值得的，女士。抱歉。抱歉。哦，熊来了。你听见了吗？你听听这风声和等待有多长？
the blood-stained cloth that they have tied at the tip of the spear. They are going to try to lure this bear with the smell of blood. There is no dialogue for over two minutes as they wait for the bear. It's just wind and waiting and it is so creepy and I think you have to hear it. This is two minutes of wind? Yes. Okay. It's worth it lady. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Oh, the bear's there. Did you hear it? Did you hear how much wind and waiting?
这真是一种极度悬疑的氛围。悬疑感十足。风刮得真大啊，女士。我还觉得这是一个很好的配乐范例，记得吗？罗杰·伊伯特指出了杰里·戈德史密斯惊人的音乐配乐。是的，很棒。很棒。风声与音乐的结合。但你看你们等了多久，就只是听着风声并等待这头熊的出现。好吧，熊来了。哦，是的。
That is some serious suspense. Very suspenseful. That is a lot of wind, lady. And I also thought that was a really nice example of the score, remember? Roger Ebert pointed out the amazing musical score by Jerry Goldsmith. Yeah, it's good. It's good. Combo wind and music. But look how long you're waiting and you're just listening to the wind and waiting for this bear. Well, the bear comes. Oh, yeah.
直接冲向他们。他们试图把熊引向用树枝在地上标记的一个“X”形区域，因为他们不知怎么弄的——他们怎么能做出所有这些东西？一个巨大的像某种东西，上面有这些木质长矛伸出来。他们做了一个老派中世纪风格的摆锤式秋千，一个挂着一束尖锐长矛的巨大圆球，他们到时候只要砍断绳子，它就会荡起来砸中熊。他们还花了大把大把的时间削木头。哦。而且如果我没记错的话，他们只有一把刀。是的，他们得轮流来。他们不得不疯狂地
Comes right at them. And they try to lure the bear to this like X that they've marked on the ground with some twigs because they've made somehow, how do they make all this stuff? A big like something with like these wooden spears coming out of it. They made like an old school medieval sort of like pendulum swing, a giant ball with a bunch of pointy spears that they're gonna like cut the rope and it's gonna swing and it's gonna hit the bear. They've also spent a ton of time whittling. Oh. And they have one knife, if I'm correct here. Yeah, they had to take turns. They had to whittle their
削木头。他们一整晚都在削木头。他们没睡觉，一整晚都在削木头。他们确实这么做了，不幸的是，当他们放下那个中世纪的大物件、带刺的东西时，它先撞到了一棵树，这在某种程度上打破了它的动量，然后它才撞到了熊，那种感觉就像是——哦天哪，对熊来说简直不痛不痒。那只熊的反应就像是——就像是熊被扇了一巴掌，然后它心想：嘿，搞什么鬼。接着熊就生气了。然后熊真的怒了，我觉得我们剖析这部电影绝对不能不放一下熊的叫声。哦，让我们听听它的声音。吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼吼.太可怕了。它在他们脸上咆哮，而他们手里只有那种自己削的木棍，
hearts out. They spent all night whittling. They didn't sleep, they whittled all night. They certainly did and unfortunately when they let the big medieval thingy, spiky thing down, it hits a tree first, which sort of breaks the momentum and then it hits the bear and it's like oh my gosh it's like nothing to the bear. The bear's like, it's like the bear got slapped and he's like hey what the hell. Then the bear's mad. Then the bear's really mad and I kind of feel like we can't do a breakdown of this movie and not hear the bear. Oh let's hear him. Rrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr rrr. Yes. He's terrifying. Growling in their faces and all they have are like these self-whittled wooden branches
顶端带有一个小尖头。他们最后只好逃跑。他们——又是一次漫长的追逐，穿过树林，冲下堤岸，进入水中。但女士，在他们削木头的那个夜晚，他们其实是计划好这一出的，因为他们打算从堤岸上跳下去，尽可能快地滚下去，好为他们争取一点时间前往第二个据点。是的，带了很多长矛。更多的长矛。各位，他们必须在黑暗中
with a little pointy thing on the end. They end up running away. They, again, this is another like long pursuit, like through woods, down an embankment, into some water. But lady, in their night of whittling they planned this because they're gonna dive off the embankment, you're gonna roll down it as fast they can to give them a little bit of time to go to their second staging area. Yes, with many spears. A lot more spears. You guys they had to do
完成这一切。他们不得不一整晚不停地削啊削啊削啊削，然后必须在黑暗中冲下堤岸。他们必须在黑暗中过河。然后他们必须安放他们剩下的那些长矛。你差不多只能顺着剧情看下去，因为这有点——你完全可以吐槽他们在短短一个晚上居然能干完这么多活，
this in the dark. They had to whittle, whittle, whittle, whittle, whittle all night, then they had to go down an embankment in the dark. They had to cross a river in the dark. Then they had to place their other spears. You kind of just have to go with it because that's a little, you could call bullsh-t on how much they had to do in a night,
但你得放过这一点。你得放过它，必须的。他们来到了他们那个小水滨堡垒似的地方。长矛区。值得赞扬的是，当查尔斯处于熊的危险之中时，鲍勃确实挺身而出激怒了熊，然后熊转向鲍勃，猛击并袭击了他。把他撞飞了，我的意思是熊把他们两个都撞飞了，
but you gotta let it go. You gotta let it go, you do. They get down to their little waterfront fortress thing. Spear area. And to his credit, when Charles is in peril with the bear, Bob does step up and antagonize the bear, and then the bear turns on Bob and swipes him and gets him. Sends him flying, I mean the bear knocked them both,
就像砰砰一样。对，但查尔斯跑去拿了一根长矛，把他们撞飞了。我的意思是熊把他们两个都撞飞了，就像砰砰一样。对，但查尔斯跑去拿了一根长矛，他完成了一个极其惊艳的动作，他把长矛的尾端撑在一些岩石上。来真正固定住它。对，然后他的选择是，他必须让熊向他冲过来，然后扑到他身上。把自己刺穿。他真的这么做了。熊把自己刺穿了，然后轰然倒在查尔斯身上。1700磅重的身躯压在查尔斯身上。对。
like pew pew. Yeah, but Charles runs and gets a spear,ends them flying. I mean the bear knocked them both like yeah pew pew. Yeah but Charles runs and gets a spear and he does this amazing moment where he sort of braces the back of the spear into some rocks. To really anchor it. Yes and then his option is he has to let the bear charge him and like fall on him. Impale himself. And he does. The bear impales himself and then collapses dead on top of Charles. 1700 pounds collapsing on Charles. Yeah.
我当时觉得他死定了。好吧，他没死。他们做到了。他们杀死了这头熊，镜头一转，他们正在火上烤熊肉吃。是的，根据詹姆斯的影评——我知道你不是他的粉丝——这是1997年电影中他给出的最佳反律师笑话。再次抱歉，他的负面评价其实是另一个正面评价。好吧，随便吧，两颗星就两颗星，詹姆斯，究竟要怎样你才肯满意？1997年上映的电影有很多，各位。这对于最佳反律师笑话来说已经是极高的赞誉了。鲍勃对查尔斯说，一个月前，老斯莫基（熊的名字）要是这么人立而起，你大概早就叫律师了。而查尔斯说，不，我不会对一只动物做这种事。我不会对一只动物做这种事。Boom，啪！对。是的。
I kind of thought he was a goner. Well, he's not. They did it. They killed this bear and we're gonna cut to them cooking the bear meat over a fire. Yes and according to James's review I know you're not a fan of him here is his best anti-lawyer joke in a movie in 1997. I'm sorry again his negative review is another positive review. Okay fine but two stars whatever again what does it
这一晚，他们什么都没削，但他们烤了熊肉，吃了熊肉，
take James what does it take? There are a lot of movies released in 1997, you guys. This is high praise for the best anti-lawyer joke. Bob is going to say to Charles, a month ago, old Smokey here would have reared up and you probably would have called your lawyer. And Charles says, nah, I wouldn't do that to an animal. I wouldn't do that to an animal. Baboom, choo! Yeah. Yep. On this night, they don't whittle anything, but they do cook the bear, eat the bear,
剥了熊皮，用熊皮做了衣服，用熊皮做了背包。这让我陷入了一个深渊：剥一张熊皮到底需要多长时间，以及所有这些细节。这需要很长时间，特别是用那种大小的刀。我觉得我现在对怎么剥熊皮知道得太多了，比如我知道你是从肛门开始剥的。什么？你知道。为什么？别告诉我。总之，你要把爪子和头部留着。这可是一整套流程。这本来需要花费大量时间的。
skin the bear, make clothing out of the bear, make a backpack out of the bear. This sent me down the rabbit hole of how long does it take to skin a bear and all the things. It takes a really long time especially with a knife that size. I feel like I know too much now about how to even skin a bear like I know you started the anus. What?, you do. Why? Don't tell me. Anyway, you leave the paws and the head on. It's a whole thing. This would have taken so much time.
听着，他们有可能确实在这个地方扎营了一段时间。这并不明确。这不明确。这是一个时间剪辑。是的，可能有一段时间过去了，因为下一个大场面是他们在山顶上，他们转过身来，身上穿着全套的熊皮衣。我说这是我唯一要狠狠吐槽的一帧。看起来太疯狂了。是的，他们穿上了，他们有一种重获新生的自信。他们吃饱了。这东西不再跟踪他们了。现在他们用
Listen, it's possible that they did camp here for a period of time. It's not clear. It's not clear. It is a time cut. Yes, there could have been a passage of time because the next big scene is them on a mountaintop, they turn around and they are in full bearskin outfits. I said this is the one shot I'm calling this **** on. It looks crazy. Yeah, they are, they have a sort of renewed confidence. They have eaten. This thing is not stalking them anymore. And now they've made a compass
查尔斯怀表里的零件做了一个指南针。正是在这个时候，查尔斯说，你知道吗，等这一切结束了，等我们回到家，我要重新开始我的生活。是的，他想要一次重来的机会。他确实想。想要指出的是，在一小时二十五分钟的时候，风在群山中呼啸着，
out of Charles's pocket watch. And this is when Charles says, you know what, when this is over, when we get home, I'm gonna start my life over again. Yeah, he wants a do-over. He does. Wanna point out at one hour and 25 minutes, wind is whistling through the mountains
当他们开始赶路时。你能感受到那种辽阔感。这里有风效的处理。如果我可以去找音效剪辑师，为他们出色的风效处理击掌叫好，我一定会这么做的。好吧，我对此并不否认。就着这个话题，我们休息一下。等我们回来，我们将进入电影的最后幕。
as they start their walk. You just feel the vastness. There's a wind placement. If I could go to the sound editor and give them a high five for really good wind placement, I would. Well, I don't disagree. And on that note, let's take a break. And when we come back, we will get to the final act of the movie.
音乐 好了，我们回来了，在穿着熊皮衣走了很长一段时间后，鲍勃和查尔斯偶然发现了一个棚屋。一个带有独木舟的棚屋。说实话，女士，看到这个棚屋时，我希望他们能有更激烈的反应。我懂你的意思，因为看到这个棚屋你会有多他妈兴奋啊？我太兴奋了。你看到这个棚屋时不兴奋吗？我太兴奋了。你在开玩笑吧？顺便说一句，这个棚屋看起来好像已经被废弃了无数年，
MUSIC All right, we are back and after a very long time of walking in their bare skin outfits, Bob and Charles come across a shack. A shack with a canoe. And lady, I needed a bigger reaction at seeing this shack. I hear you because how f***ing excited are you to see this shack? I'm so excited. Are you to see this shack? I'm so excited. Are you kidding me? And by the way, it is, this shack looks like it has been abandoned forever
正在分崩离析，根本算不上什么真正的庇护所，除非你在荒野中已经流浪了不知多久。是的。这看起来就像一座豪宅。是的。我需要他们的反应是那种“哦天哪”或者类似的话。
and is falling apart and is in no way any kind of real shelter, except when you have been living out in the wilderness for however long they've been gone. Yeah. This looks like a mansion. Yeah. I needed them to be like, oh my god, or something.
是的，他们只是径直走进去，开始着手翻找避难所里的所有东西。顺便说一句，这是我最喜欢求生电影的部分，当人们找到类似这样的地方，他们可以搜寻所有的新物资。这就是我喜欢丧尸电影的部分，就像在《活死人黎明》里，他们穿过商场，
Yeah, they just sort of just walk in and get down to the business of looking through all the contents of the shelter. This is my favorite part of survival films, by the way, is when the people find something like this, where they get to root for all their new supplies. It's the part of zombie movies that I like, like in Dawn of the Dead, when they go through the mall
收集他们为了生存而想要的所有东西。我不看丧尸电影。我不会——是的。但我知道你说的那个时刻。我只是讨厌丧尸。事情是这样的，当他们走向这个废弃的小木屋时，
and they get all the things they wanna gather for their survival. I don't watch zombie movies. I'm not gonna, yeah. But I know the moment you're talking about. I just hate zombies. Here's the thing, as they're walking up to this kind of abandoned cabin,
查尔斯看到了地上有一个捕熊器。对，就是那种用泥土掩盖起来、但下面有个洞的陷阱。上面还竖着尖锐的东西，就像他们自己——自己削的。自己削的、尖锐的东西。他只是瞥了一眼然后绕了过去。但这在后面会变得很重要。我它然后绕了过去。但这在后面会变得很重要。
Charles sees one of those bear traps in the ground. Yeah, one of the ones that it's like covered up with earth, but it goes down a hole. And there's spiky things sticking out like they've... Self-whittled. Self-whittled, spiky things. And he just kind of clocks it and walks around it. But that's going to be important later. I it and walks around it. But that's gonna be important later.
很高兴你提到了这一点。所以他们进到了里面，以下是他们找到的东西。他们找到了一个茶壶。一些威士忌。一把带子弹的步枪。一张旧地图。一张地图。是的。
I'm glad you mentioned it. So they get inside and here's what they found. They found a teapot. Some whiskey. A rifle with bullets. An old map. A map. Yeah.
还有一艘能浮起来的独木舟。能浮起来的。哦，他们太兴奋了。他们要休整一下。嗯哼。鲍勃威士忌喝得挺猛。查尔斯则说：我要去烧茶。哦，那是你在这部电影中最喜欢的片段吗？这就像我喜欢《疾速追杀》里的咖啡机时刻一样？对你来说也是这样的吗？他在荒野中，要赶快给自己泡点茶。我太为他能喝上一杯热茶感到兴奋了。是的。但查尔斯分心了。
And a canoe that floats. That floats. Oh, they're so excited. They're gonna like kind of gather themselves. Mm-hmm. Bob is hitting the whiskey pretty hard. Charles is like, I'm gonna make tea. Oh, was that your favorite part of the movie? Was this like how I loved the John Wick coffee maker moment? Was this that for you? Where he's gonna, he's in the wilderness, he's gonna make himself some tea real quick. I was so excited for him to have a hot cup of tea. Yeah. But Charles gets distracted.
好吧，是的，因为现在这部电影的最终章要开始了。第一章，人与荒野的对抗。第二章，人与熊的对抗。而现在最后一章是人与人的对抗。因为当查尔斯开始为他的茶壶生火时，你猜他发现了什么？他找到了那两块手表和那把刀的收据。所以他现在知道了他妻子买下了所有这三样东西，包括刻有感谢鲍勃“所有那些美妙夜晚”字样的鲍勃的手表。
Well, yes, because now is going to begin the final chapter of this movie. Chapter one, we had man against the wilderness. Chapter two, man against bear. And now the final chapter is man against man. Because as Charles is starting the fire for his teapot, guess what he finds? He finds the receipt for both watches and the knife. So he knows now that his wife bought all three including Bob's watch that was engraved thanking Bob for quote, all the nights.
是的，爱你的米奇。所以查尔斯看着这张收据。他在脑海里把这一切串联起来。他知道发生了什么。与此同时，鲍勃正在猛灌威士忌，并往步枪里装子弹。是的。查尔斯看着他说：“清醒着就干不下去了，是吧？”
Yeah, love Mickey. So Charles is looking at this receipt. He's adding it all up in his brain. He knows what happened. Meanwhile, Bob is just swinging whiskey and loading the rifle with bullets. Yeah. Charles looks at him and says, can't do it sober, huh?
是的，非常喜欢米老鼠。所以查尔斯正在看着这张收据。他在脑海里把所有东西加起来。他知道发生了什么。与此同时，鲍勃正晃荡着威士忌，往步枪里装子弹。是的。查尔斯看着他说，清醒的时候干不了，对吧？
And he says, yeah, I guess you can kill me now that you don't need me anymore. Now that you know you can just ride this canoe down the river. You don't really need me. And Bob is like, you had no business being with that broad. Everybody knows it. She was just with you for the money. Yeah. He says, Let's go marches him outside. Wants him to turn around. He's going to shoot him in the back. Yeah. Charles won't turn around. Lady. I have a question. What is it? Was Bob always going to kill Charles? This is where it is confusing. It is confusing. Yeah at first, I just think that he was kind of happy to have an affair with his wife
然后他说，好吧，既然你不再需要我了，我想你可以杀了我。既然你知道你可以顺着河划独木舟。你其实并不需要我。鲍勃就说，你根本不该跟那个荡妇在一起。人人都知道。她跟你在一起只是为了钱。对。他说，我们走吧，把他带到外面。让他转过身去。他打算从背后开枪打死他。对。查尔斯就是不肯转身。女士。我有个问题。什么问题？鲍勃是不是一直都打算杀了查尔斯？这就是让人糊涂的地方。确实挺糊涂的。对，一开始，我只是觉得他挺高兴能和别人的妻子有一腿
and didn't like Charles, but was just going to do this photo shoot. He's a douchebag, but he isn't going to kill him. Right. When did he decide to kill him? I think that what Charles was picking up on at the beginning of the movie when he says, how are you gonna kill me, Bob?
而且不喜欢查尔斯，但本来只是打算拍这组照片。他是个混蛋，但并不打算杀他。没错。他是什么时候决定杀他的？我觉得查尔斯在电影开头时就已经察觉到了，当时他说，鲍勃，你打算怎么杀我？
He's picking up on the idea that he knows that Bob has it in him, that he's the kind of man who has thought, wouldn't it be great if Charles died and then we got all the money? I don't think he thinks, oh, this man will actually murder me, but he knows he's had the thought. That's what I think the scab he's picking at when he says that, that he says,
他察觉到，也知道鲍勃心里确实有这个念头，他就是那种会想“要是查尔斯死了，然后我们就能得到所有的钱，那该多好”的男人。我不认为他觉得，哦，这个人真的会谋杀我，但他知道鲍勃动过这个念头。这就是我觉得他当时在戳穿的痛处，他说，
I know the character of you. You're a man of poor character, because you would wish me dead so you can have my wife and my money. OK. And then that's what I imagine. I don't think, think obviously Bob didn't make a flock of geese fly into this plane and make them stranded. But it would explain why he didn't stick around after the plane crash or took off running when
我了解你的人品。你这个人品行败坏，因为你希望我死，这样你就能得到我的妻子和我的钱。好吧。然后这就是我的想象。我当然不觉得鲍勃是故意让一群大雁撞上飞机并让他们搁浅的。但这就能解释为什么飞机坠毁后他没有留下来，或者在
bears attacking Stephen. Yeah. But now he sees his opportunity. Yeah, at this point, Charles could just, quote, not survive this. And he can go back and have the wife and all the money. So yeah, but I don't think he was always going to kill Charles. It wasn't. This is a man of opportunity. That's the character that he is, right?
熊袭击斯蒂芬时逃跑了。对。但现在他看到了机会。对，在这个时候，查尔斯可以说是“注定无法生还”了。而他可以回去，拥有妻子和所有的钱。所以，是的，但我不认为他一直都打算杀查尔斯。他不是。这是一个见机行事的人。他就是这种性格的人，对吧？
Yeah. He takes advantage of opportunity. That's the character that he is, right? Yeah. He takes advantage of opportunities. This is probably an unpopular opinion, but I wrote, I didn't need this part. What part? Man against man. Oh, I love man against man. I liked the survival.
对。他利用机会。他就是这种性格的人，对吧？对。他利用机会。这可能是一个不受欢迎的观点，但我写道，我不需要这一段。哪一段？人与人的较量。哦，我喜欢人与人的较量。我喜欢生存。
I like the outwitting. This is the outwitting. This is the part of Survivor where you have to outwit. Yeah. Yeah. Well, Bob has him outside now. Yeah. He has him at gunpoint.
我喜欢斗智。这就是斗智。这就是《幸存者》里你必须斗智斗勇的部分。对。对。好了，现在鲍勃把他带到了外面。对。他用枪指着他。
And Charles will not turn around. He doesn't think Bob's ultimately gonna do it. And Bob kind of takes a step back right into the bear pit, full of spiky things. Yes, and his leg gets impaled. Like he has clearly, the way it's twisted, it's clearly broken during the fall and it has a giant spike through it now, a wooden spike.
而查尔斯就是不肯转身。他以为鲍勃最终不会开枪。结果鲍勃往后退了一步，正好掉进了满是尖刺的熊坑里。是的，他的腿被刺穿了。从那个扭曲的姿势来看，他在坠落时显然骨折了，现在上面还插着一根巨大的尖刺，一根木刺。
It's totally mangled. Here's my question, did Charles intend to push him back into that bear pit? Yes. Yes. This is where he's the rabbit with the pipe. Correct. Yeah, he knew it. Well now Charles jumps into the pit to help him.
简直血肉模糊。我的问题是，查尔斯是故意把他推回那个熊坑里的吗？是的。是的。这就是他扮演带着烟斗的兔子的时刻。没错。是的，他知道。好吧，现在查尔斯跳进坑里去救他。
I mean, carefully, he doesn't jump into it, but he gets down in there. Yep, he takes all the bullets out of the gun. He tourniquets his leg, and then we've got a cut. We never see him do it, but somehow he gets him out of the pit and puts him on the table up in the cabin. It's fine, jump cut, it's fine. It's fine.
我是说，小心翼翼地，他不是直接跳进去的，而是下到里面去了。对，他把枪里的所有子弹都卸了下来。他给他的腿上了止血带，然后镜头一转。我们从没看到他是怎么做到的，但他不知怎么地把鲍勃从坑里弄了出来，放到了木屋里的桌子上。没关系，跳切，没关系。没关系。
Bob is in a ton of pain. He passes out from the pain. Yeah. And Charles is now going to sit and weirdly read the first aid brochure as if there's anything in there. There's a first aid kit in the wall of this cabin and he's reading this brochure
鲍勃痛得要命。他疼得昏了过去。对。而查尔斯现在坐在那里，极其诡异地读着急救手册，就好像那里面能有什么用似的。这个木屋的墙上有个急救箱，他在读这本手册
as if he's gonna find any information on how to help this leg. Like every time I see this part of the movie, I'm like, what does he think he's finding in this booklet? While he's sitting there, lady, I want you to know all you can hear. Oh, boy. Is it wind, lady? It is wind.
就好像他能在里面找到如何处理这条腿的信息一样。每次我看到电影的这一段，我都想，他到底觉得这小册子里能找到什么？正当他坐在那里时，女士，我想让你听到所有的声音。哦，天哪。是风的声音吗，女士？确实是风。
More wind. One hour, 40 minutes. Bob finally comes to, and Charles tells him, you know what, we're going to get out of here. I want to point out, as they board the canoe, neither of them have their fancy bearskin outfits anymore. No. They've ditch their fancy bearskin outfits anymore. No. They've ditched the bearskin look. Well Charles is still wearing his bear tooth around his neck. Yes but he does still have his necklace. Not the poncho he spent so many
更多的风。一个小时四十分钟。鲍勃终于醒了过来，查尔斯告诉他，你知道吗，我们要离开这里了。我要指出的是，当他们登上独木舟时，他们都不再穿着那些华丽的熊皮衣服了。没有。他们不再穿着那些华丽的熊皮衣服了。没有。他们抛弃了熊皮造型。不过查尔斯脖子上还戴着那颗熊牙。是的，他确实还留着那条项链。不再是他花了那么多
hours making. Right. Yeah. Or the bearskin jacket that Bob had on. Yes. Again we don't ever see how Charles got Bob in the canoe, but they're now sailing down the river. And they're going to have a conversation. Bob is going to ask Charles, why did you save me after everything that's happened? And Charles says, it's a challenge. And Bob says, I think it's because you've never
小时制作的斗篷了。没错。对。也没有鲍勃身上穿的那件熊皮夹克。是的。同样，我们从没看到查尔斯是怎么把鲍勃弄上独木舟的，但他们现在正顺流而下。他们要聊一聊。鲍勃要问查尔斯，经历了这一切之后，你为什么还要救我？查尔斯说，这是一种挑战。鲍勃说，我想那是因为你从来没有
had a friend. Yeah. They have found this little island in the middle of the river and they have made a fire. To kind of warm up Bob who's not looking great. Not looking great. I know I should not have found this humorous, but Bob repeatedly says, I'm not feeling 100%. Well, it doesn't look good. You think?
过朋友。对。他们在河中间发现了这个小岛，并生起了火。好给状况不太好的鲍勃取暖。状况不太好了。我知道我不该觉得搞笑，但鲍勃反复说，我感觉状态不是百分之百的好。好吧，这看起来可不太妙。你觉得呢？
Yeah, he doesn't look good. And that's when Bob is going to, he's gonna start crying. And he kind of knows he's dying. And he says, I've done nothing with my life and I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry, I want you to know something. Mickey was never part of the plan to kill you. No.
对，他看起来确实不太妙。就在这时，鲍勃要开始哭了。他心里清楚自己快要死了。他说，我这一生什么都没做，我真的很抱歉，我真的很抱歉，我想让你知道一件事。米奇从来都不是杀你计划的一部分。不。
Well, I guess now it seems like there was a plan to kill him. He just says she was never in on it. Any of this business out here, she wasn't in on it. Yeah. I, what? Well, we don't know. And Charles is like, Bob, come on, it's fine. Bob, don't die on me.
好吧，我想现在看起来确实曾有过一个杀他的计划。他只是说她从来没有参与其中。外面的这些破事，她根本没参与。我，什么？好吧，我们不知道。查尔斯就说，鲍勃，得了吧，没事的。鲍勃，别死在我怀里。
Don't die on me, Bob. And then what do we hear in the distance? What do we hear? Helicopter. A helicopter. Charles is so excited. He starts waving his coat in the air and you kind of think the helicopter is not gonna see him.
别死在我怀里，鲍勃。然后我们在远处听到了什么？我们听到了什么？直升机。一架直升机。查尔斯兴奋极了。他开始在空中挥舞着外套，你甚至会觉得直升机看不到他。
And then at the last minute, it turns towards them. And you know they're saved. Yes. And he runs back to Bob. And he's like, they're coming. We are saved. Bob's dead. Bob's dead.
然后在最后一刻，直升机转向了他们。你知道他们得救了。是的。他跑回鲍勃身边。他说，他们来了。我们得救了。鲍勃死了。鲍勃死了。
And remember what Charles said, most men die of in the wilderness. He died of shame because he couldn't go back. He couldn't face himself. And I don't think it's the wilderness. He died of shame because he couldn't go back. He couldn't face himself. And I don't think it's the affair. What he couldn't face was that he was willing to kill Charles. He couldn't live with himself. And Charles saved him even after that. So he died of shame. Well now the helicopter is arriving back at the lodge. Yeah there's's all these reporters. Yeah, they're kind of
还记得查尔斯说过的话吗，大多数人在荒野中是怎么死的？他是因为羞耻而死的，因为他无法回去。他无颜面对自己。我不认为那是荒野。他是因为羞耻而死的，因为他无法回去。他无颜面对自己。我不认为是因为那段婚外情。他无法面对的是自己曾想要杀害查尔斯。他无法原谅自己。而查尔斯在那种情况下依然救了他。所以他是羞愧而死的。现在直升机正载着他们飞回度假村。对，有好多记者。对，他们被
being held back by like, yeah, police and Charles gets off the plane. He starts walking up to the lodge. I mean, and he looks like he's been through it. Well, he has he has been through it. Yeah. And Charles as he walks past Krusty Stiles says to Stiles, why is the rabbit unafraid to which styles replies because he's smarter than the panther and they share a knowing smile that's pretty dark lady yeah we're also now gonna see Bob's body is being unloaded from the plane you know he's all covered up and Mickey you see Mickey standing there stoically waiting for her husband, but then also kind of, she's tearing up. She's looking at, she sees Bob down, make it.
警察什么的拦在后面，查尔斯从飞机上下来。他开始朝度假村走去。我的意思是，他看起来经历了很多。好吧，他确实经历了很多。没错。当查尔斯走过克拉斯蒂·斯泰尔斯身边时，他对斯泰尔斯说，为什么兔子无所畏惧？斯泰尔斯回答说，因为兔子比美洲豹更聪明。他们相视一笑，心照不宣。这挺黑暗的，女士。对，我们现在还要看到鲍勃的遗体从飞机上卸下来，你知道他被完全盖住了。而米奇，你看到米奇站在那里，坚忍地等待着她的丈夫，但随后她也有些动容，眼眶湿润了。她看着，她看到鲍勃倒下了，米奇。
There's all these reporters have gathered and Charles goes up and looks at Mickey for a long time, gives her a hug and then puts Bob's watch in her hand. And then puts Bob's watch in her hand. Yep. For all the nights. Mm-hmm. And then the reporters are clamoring for a statement, and Charles is going to give us the final wisdom from the movie. Here it is. Ah, we're all put to the test, but it never comes in the form or at the point we would prefer,
聚集了这么多的记者，查尔斯走上前去看了米奇很久，给了她一个拥抱，然后把鲍勃的手表放进她手里。然后把鲍勃的手表放进她手里。是的。为了所有的夜晚。嗯哼。然后记者们蜂拥而上要求发表声明，查尔斯将给出这部电影最后的智慧。就是这个。啊，我们都经受了考验，但它从来都不是以我们偏爱的方式或在 我们偏爱的时候降临，
does it? That's right. In our lifetimes, every single one of us is put to the test. It's not going to come in the form or at the time you would prefer. But we'll all be put to the test somehow, some way. And so, are you gonna walk out of it? Are ya? Are you gonna die of shame? Which to me is just another way of saying are you gonna give up? Are you gonna give up and give in?
对吧？没错。在我们的一生中，我们每一个人都经受了考验。它不会以你偏爱的方式或在你偏爱的时间降临。但我们都会以某种方式、某种途径经受考验。所以，你能挺过去吗？你会吗？你会羞愧至死吗？对我来说，这只是换了一种说法，问你是不是要放弃？你要放弃并认输吗？
Are you gonna walk out of it? Because what one man can do another can do. That's right. Your test is no different than someone else's test. It might be a different form. It might be a different time. But we will all have a test. Can you rise to the occasion?
你能挺过去吗？因为别人能做到事，你也能做到。没错。你的考验和别人的考验没什么不同。形式可能会有所不同。时间可能会有所不同。但我们都会经历考验。你能迎难而上吗？
That's what this movie is asking. And that is why I love this movie. Yeah. As you were saying that, I thought about, it's a verse. I'm going to paraphrase it. God is no respecter of persons, meaning God does not show favoritism or partiality towards any individual. Like you get what you get. And that's what I was thinking. And what do you do with it? What do you do with it? Yeah.
这就是这部电影要探讨的问题。这也是我热爱这部电影的原因。对。当你这么说的时候，我想到了，这是一段经文。我用我自己的话来意译一下。上帝不偏待任何人，意思是上帝对任何个人都没有偏爱或偏袒。就像你得到什么就是什么。这就是我当时想的。你拿它怎么办？你拿它怎么办？对。
Yeah. Well, at the end, a reporter asked Charles, how did his friends die? And he really tears up. It's very emotional. And he says, they died saving my life. And it's making me tear up because of the other part of this movie which is that you do not
对。好吧，在最后，一个记者问查尔斯，他的朋友是怎么死的？他真的泪流满面。非常感人。他说，他们是为了救我的命而死的。这让我感动得流泪，因为这部电影的另一个主题是，你并不是
do it alone. You don't do any of it alone. I did not do my cancer journey alone. Angela you were there every step of the way and so was my husband and so were all the nurses and the doctors and so were all the parents of my children's friends and there is a community for all of us when we are put to the test. There is. You have to find it. You have to let it in. Mm-hmm.
一个人在战斗。你做任何事都不是孤身一人。我的抗癌之旅就不是孤身一人。安吉拉，你每一步都陪伴在我身边，我丈夫也是，所有的护士和医生也是，我孩子朋友们的父母也是，当我们经受考验时，我们所有人都有一个社群作为后盾。确实如此。你必须找到它。你必须敞开心扉接受它。嗯哼。
You know? People will give themselves to you in so many ways to help you. They will. Yeah. I thought a lot about that last line of the movie. I'm always curious about first lines of movies and last lines. You know, what are the bookends? Yeah. What was the first line of this movie? The first line of this movie is actually by the character Mickey, and she turns to her husband, Charles, as she takes in the vast wilderness and she says, Charles, isn't this great?
你知道吗？人们会以各种各样的方式向你奉献自己来帮助你。他们真的会的。对。我琢磨了很多电影的最后一句台词。我总是对电影的第一句台词和最后一句台词很好奇。你知道，首尾呼应是什么？对。这部电影的第一句台词是什么？这部电影的第一句台词其实是米奇这个角色说的，她转过身对她的丈夫查尔斯说，当她环顾这片广袤的荒野时，她说，查尔斯，这难道不棒吗？
Wow. Yeah. And what I think Charles is talking about when he says they died saving my life, because Stephen didn't save his life. Bob didn't really either. But in a way way all of it made him realize that he wants a do-over.
哇。对。而我认为查尔斯说他们是为了救我的命时，他指的是，因为斯蒂芬并没有救他的命。鲍勃其实也没有。但在某种程度上，这一切让他意识到他想要重来一次。
Yeah, I also think that in a way just their being there did save his life because it gave Charles purpose. To get out. He wasn't ever alone. Right. Being alone in the wilderness is a lot harder than being with two other people in the wilderness yeah whatever your wilderness is right you know and so just their presence kept him going yeah yeah I think that's true you You know? Well, that was the edge, you guys.
对，我也觉得在某种程度上，他们的存在确实救了他的命，因为这给了查尔斯活下去的目标。去走出去。他从来都不是孤单一人。没错。独自一人在荒野中要比和另外两个人一起在荒野中艰难得多，无论你的荒野是什么，对吧，所以仅仅是他们的存在就支撑着他继续走下去。对，对，我觉得确实如此。你知道吗？好了，这就是边缘，各位。
And Lady, I know I watched this as a Galentine's gift to you, but maybe it was a gift to myself. Well, I hope it was. I hope it was the greatest gift ever. I mean, it was a good gift. It was a good gift. I don't know if it's the greatest gift ever, but I really did enjoy it.
女士，我知道我看这部电影是作为情人节礼物送给你的，但也许它也是送给我自己的礼物。好吧，我希望它是。我希望它是史上最棒的礼物。我的意思是，这确实是一份好礼物。这是一份好礼物。我不知道它是不是史上最棒的礼物，但我真的很喜欢它。
Well, thank you, Lady. Thank you to everyone for writing in and for watching this along with us. I really mean it. I appreciate you sharing this movie that I love so much. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey.
好吧，谢谢你，女士。谢谢所有写信来以及和我们一起观看这部电影的人。我是认真的。我很感激你们分享这部我如此热爱的电影。我们下周见。到时见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”是奥德赛（Odyssey）呈献的节目，由珍娜·菲舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）制作。
Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubbico）。奥德赛的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼（Jenna Weiss-Berman）和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯（Leah Reese-Dennis）。“办公室女士”由克里斯·巴西尔（Chris Basil）进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《橡胶树》（Rubber Tree）。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。